how would you describe what being a simp  is for people who don't know what that  means so a simp is a transcendent nice  guy he is the type of guy that placates  to a woman that pedestalizes her and  engages in undue praise and gives gifts  for the sake of receiving emotional  connection and sex so there is no  emotional connection there is no genuine  interest in a woman he's simply doing it  because praising her and giving her  gifts because he wants something in  return so simp is within modern parlors  it's used to describe a male that is  subservient wow that might have been the  best definition of a simp that i've  heard thank you